democrats have made it very clear they
plan to put joe biden in the white house
in january whether he wins the election
or not
watch joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is gonna drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch and if we are as focused and
relentless
as the other side is another angry rich
lady boy there are a lot of those around
well today jeff bezos's personal
newspaper the washington post reported
that
violence is likely if joe biden doesn't
win
but of course not predicted if he does
win which tells you everything
and according to boston globe biden's
surrogate john podesta has been planning
for the possibility that biden won't
concede
and that the military will get involved
and make sure he's president it's hard
to believe
anyone would say that out loud but
people are saying that out loud so what
is going to happen in november
well vince collins has gamed it out he's
a radio show host at wmal in washington
and an editor at the daily caller we're
happy to have him on tonight vince
thanks so much
for coming on what do you think what are
the scenarios what's likely to happen
what election day well as you know
politics is typically very hard to
predict this one is not hard to predict
at all this election day
is setting up to be a dumpster fire an
unquenchable one actually
you know a lot of people think back to
the chaos of the 2000 election
pregnant shads hanging chads looking at
ballots in florida
thinking boy i hope that never happens
again i'm sorry that is a maskless walk
in the park
compared to what we're about to
experience and what i mean by that is
this year experts predict that upwards
of 156 million americans
will cast a ballot in the presidential
election that's a huge number
and some 80 million of those will be
cast
by mail this is unprecedented we are
over
overhauling our election system this
year uh in a way
that is really meaningful in one of the
most fraught political environments that
anyone has seen who's alive today
so in order to do that does the mail
system work well
there are a lot of question marks about
that especially because we've had so
many primaries this year
already and look at what happened in
nevada in pennsylvania
in new york where 84 thousand ballots
were just dis were disappeared that was
one
out of every four voters not counted for
they were rejected
in new york how could you have a system
where a single battleground state is in
question because of a lapse
like that that is going to be a disaster
my sense is that democrats plan to win
this election in the weeks
after election day with lawyers so if
it's a contest between
the parties on the question of who's got
more lawyers the democrats obviously
have a massive advantage it's the party
of lawyers
do you get the feeling that's their
that's their program yes they have an
army of lawyers and a
an again unquenchable desire to win you
heard it vocalized there by one of the
most famous democrats hillary clinton
uh saying that under no circumstance
should joe biden concede this election
john podesta as you mentioned was her
campaign chairman the war game that they
gamed out in june
was essentially this that come the
election
he would refuse to concede playing joe
biden
and that he would challenge the results
of the electoral college they would
manipulate the actual electors to the
electoral college
and in their war game scenario three
states washington
oregon uh and c and sorry uh uh
uh california all three of the states on
the western seaboard threaten to secede
from the union
and this is this is not these are not
french people these are this is the
center of the democrat party john
podesta
that is a big deal and they say they
want to wait for the military at that
point to figure out who's president of
the united states that was by the way a
scenario where joe biden loses
the election it's a gigantic deal so i
think there really is only one solution
to all of this
and it's we've got to get the polls open
we have very little time but it is of
immense
importance that people vote in person if
americans can't have confidence in their
election system
the whole thing falls apart we have such
low trust in our institutions today
at all levels government media
everywhere if you lose faith in your
election
that's how you become third world open
up the polls
congress can use its com its compulsory
capabilities
threaten funding force these states to
reopen whatever you
have to do enfranchise every american
voter you possibly can
because right now the state's governors
are shutting down polls across the
country
and it is safe to vote doctors fauci and
dr burks they say
it's safe to get in line and cast a vote
unless you're in that very vulnerable
population then go ahead cast that
mail-in ballot
but we need a lot of confidence in this
election result and we need it quickly
i think that's a very very smart point
and it's something that republicans in
congress
not one of the sharpest groups in
america need to be reminded of so thank
you for reminding them of that open the
polls thank you
thank you